Hello everyone here on freeCodeCamp today and
welcome to this course on no SQL. My name is Ania
Kubow, and I'm a software developer and course
creator on YouTube as well as your instructor
for this video. In this video course, I will
be demystifying what no SQL is clarifying the
difference between SQL and no SQL as well as going
into a deep dive of the four main types of no SQL
databases. With each deep dive, we will be
approaching each learning as an explanation,
example and exercise. So the three is in order
to fully grasp the topic we are discussing.
After that, we will go straight into using what
we have learned with two real life use cases.
By use cases, I mean, we will be getting data
into real life projects using a document API,
and the Graph QL API to communicate with
our newly made databases. And finally,
we'll be wrapping up with where to go next. Don't
worry if none of this makes sense to you. Now,
this is what the tutorial is for. As always, if
you like what we are doing here at freeCodeCamp,
please do get that subscribe button and click as
it would really help us on our mission to provide
a broad spectrum of learning materials right here
free to access for you. Now, let's get to it.
So the first thing you need to know is that
no SQL is an approach to database management.
It is considered to be super flexible as
it allows for a variety of data models,
such as key value, document, y column or
tabular and graph formats. These are the four
we will be looking at today, as well as a new
emerging trend of multi model databases. So we
have already mentioned that no SQL databases are
casually considered to be flexible. But officially
the defining characteristics of no SQL databases
are considered to be that they are non relational,
distributed and scalable. Distributed
refers to running on clusters of machines
globally distributed to support apps at two
different geographical locations. And scalable
means that no SQL databases are able to store and
query life scale data, as well as support high
transaction throughput scaling horizontally. In
addition to this, they're also partition tolerant,
meaning that they are able to work in
the presence of network partitioning.
And they are also highly available, meaning that
they are able to serve requests even when some
machines go down. They can do this as they have
data replication built in. And lastly, what does
non relational entail? To understand this fully,
we need to look at relational databases bust, the
relational data model and SQL were designed for
databases that work on single machines and scale
vertically. We will go into this in a bit more
detail later on. In fact, everything we just
mentioned is in contrast to what relational
databases are all about, which is Atomicity,
Consistency, Isolation, durability, or acid for
short. I am bringing up relational databases as
you understand where no SQL came from,
we have to look at them as well as SQL.
SQL stands for Structured Query Language. It is
used for relational databases. By relational I
mean, it's a collection of tables with rows and
columns that stores a specific set of structured
data. No SQL is used for non relational and
relational databases. Okay, so when you think
SQL think are the Structured Query Language for
database management on relational databases,
and think rigid, and when you think no SQL? Well,
let's have a look at the word itself. No SQL,
you might think okay, so it's the more flexible
way to access data. So not using SQL destructed
query language. Simple, right? Well, you would
actually be wrong. Because of the usefulness of
SQL. Many no SQL databases added support for SQL,
leading to an understanding among developers that
no SQL actually means not only SQL. So you
can use the Structured Query Language or you
can not use the Structured Query Language,
it is up to you. So once again, to recap,
SQL is a structured query language, and no SQL is
an approach to database management. Got it? Good.
And the book No SQL distilled a brief guide
to the emerging world of polyglot persistence.
The writer explains two main reasons for using
a no SQL database. The first is application
development productivity. When developing
an app there is a significant amount of
time before starting anything really, that is
spent on organizing data. By organizing I mean,
mapping data between in memory data structures and
a relational database. So in other words a type of
database that supports SQL, as we just mentioned,
as a non relational database manager approach,
no SQL can provide a data model that better fits
the applications need an entire makes our life
easier in the long run. As the data model is more
suited to the application, it makes debugging and
writing code easier, as well as allows for easy
evolution. The second reason is large scale data.
As we know, organizations today love to capture as
much data as possible to improve their offerings
as well as other things. However, capturing
large amounts of data and processing it quickly
is expensive in terms of an operation. So whilst
it is possible to do so with relational databases,
it is usually more economic to run large data
and processes on lots and lots of little cheaper
machines or clusters that no SQL databases are
designed to explicitly run on rather than one
large one. As is typical for relational databases.
We will go into this in more detail in the next
section. So in conclusion, no SQL
is a database management approach.
The characteristics we can expect from a no SQL
database are that it is a non relational database,
as opposed to a relational one, a distributed
database that is designed to manage large scale
data while maintaining a high performance,
scalability, throughput and availability.
Now, when people look at no SQL and SQL,
they might be tempted to compare the two.
But by now we know that we can't do this. Why
again, this is because once again, no SQL is a
database management approach. And SQL is a query
language. So two completely different things, it
might be better going forward to start referring
to no SQL databases as non relational databases.
So let's go ahead and switch that. So we can start
comparing them to relational databases from now
on. As we mentioned, relational databases use this
structured query language, a language that became
prominent in the late 1970s. And no SQL means not
only Structured Query Language, which allows you
to use the language or not use it to get data. No
SQL appearance on the scene is noted as somewhere
around the 2000s. With SQL, the data is modeled
as tables with fixed columns and rows. And with
no SQL databases, the data is not only modeled
as tables with fixed rows and columns. Instead,
it can be modeled as JSON documents, graphs
with nodes and edges, key value pairs or with
Y column or tabular databases, where columns
can be dynamic from row to row within a table
instead of fixed. With a no SQL database, the
schema is flexible. This means there doesn't have
to be any real fixed structure to the data.
It can be stored in a flexible schema where
this approach can make development easier
due to the high level of flexibility.
With a relational database, the schema is fixed,
they will have rigid data types. So if you want to
put a Boolean into a column that has been
defined to only take integers, the attempt
will get rejected. Think of it as a super strict
approach. And whilst the strictness can be good,
it also comes with its downfalls and can be
very time consuming when trying to implement
changes. And finally, let's look at scalability.
No SQL usually scales out. This is also known as
horizontal scaling. This involves adding more
and more machines to the resource pool. Rather
than adding resources by scaling vertically like
relational databases do. So well no SQL scales out
SQL scales up by adding more resources I mean,
it adds things like a more powerful CPU and
RAM to handle workload and improve performance
rather than adding more machines such as service.
As mentioned, there are four main types of no
SQL database systems each using a different
data model. Once again, they are the key value
document why column or tabular and graph database
types. As mentioned we will be also taking a quick
look at the emerging trend of the multimodal type
at the end to we will be going through each type
and an explanation example exercise format. Okay,
so once again, the three is now the first thing
you need to know is that databases have multiple
layers. The first layer is an interface or in
other words, a visual platform where you can
visit and interact with data, which is where you
find the format, the language and the transport.
In this course the interface we are going to
use is called Data sex Astra database management
system. This is where we will be creating all of
our database types for the example and exercise
parts DataStax Astra DB is an auto scaling
Database as a Service built on Apache Cassandra
designed to simplify cloud native application
development. Because it is built on Apache
Cassandra, you will see us using the Cassandra
query language or CQ l a few times in this course,
CQ l offers a model close to SQL and it says that
data is put in tables containing rows and columns.
I will be pointing this out to you when we use it.
These languages are how we interact with the data
in our database. The next layer is an execution
layer. This is where we pass the incoming queries
coming from my interface. It is also used as an
analyzer and a dispatcher. And finally, we have
the storage layer in which the indexing of data
happens. The reason I'm using datasets Astra is
that it will allow us to create all four types of
database types for this tutorial, so I won't have
to sign up to separate database management systems
for each section. However, you don't have to.
There are literally dozens and dozens to choose
from, so please feel free to take your pick. We
can group these database management systems into
families according to the CIP theorem. According
to the CP theorem, a no SQL database cannot
achieve consistency, availability and partition
tolerance, it must sacrifice one of the three for
example MongoDB and Kafka chose to focus on CP and
the database management system we are going to be
using datasets Astra is not an Apache Cassandra,
which chose to focus on AP. So to recap, what
we are doing here is using data sacks Astra
which is an interface essentially, that will
allow us to work with our no SQL database,
which is in this case, Apache Cassandra, to
be exact. Apache Cassandra is an open source,
no SQL distributed database. The language
we will use to communicate with our database
is Cassandra query language, or SQL for short,
which, as I mentioned, is very similar to SQL.
Most no SQL databases have their own
query language or not. Once you are on the
data sex Astra platform, we're going to create a
database. So I'm just going to head over and click
this button right here. And that will take me to
the page in which I'm going to create our first
database, and the database name, I'm going to
call it FCC underscore tutorial, I would recommend
calling your database exactly the same in order
to avoid any issues further on for this tutorial.
Of course, once you have the knowledge
that you gained out of this tutorial,
you will be able to name your databases, anything
you wish. This is just a suggestion. However,
now under keyspace name, because the first
example we're going to look at is tables,
I'm going to call the key space Tabular.
Once again, I would recommend that you call
your key space name the same thing so that
you don't run into any issues further on.
Okay, and next we can provide a region, we
can choose Amazon Web Service, or Microsoft
Azure or Google Cloud, I'm just going to
stick with this one. And I'm just going to
select a Europe as I am currently in Europe, and
I'm going to create a database. And there we go,
we have created our first database, it has a
database ID, the status is currently pending. So
we're gonna have to wait for that to turn active
before we can go ahead and use the database.
And there we go, we're active. As you can see,
here, the status has turned to active in green.
Great. Now that we have set up our database
management system, let's start getting to some
examples. Okay, great. Now let's look at the first
database type, which is a tabular database type,
also known as a column database type or a
wide column database type. What you need to
know is that tables are relational and come with
a schema, we are going to be making a table called
books in this next section and defining what kind
of rows the table can take, and what kind of types
the rows are made of. For example, I'm going to
have a table called books. And in it, I'm going to
say that we can only have a row that has a book ID
and author a title a year release the categories
the books belongs to and a timestamp for when
it was added. I'm also going to say that the
book ID needs to be a UU ID or a universal unique
identifier. The author field needs to be some text
and the title needs to be some text to the end
has to be an integer and the categories needs
to be a set of texts. And the timestamp needs
to be a type of timestamp format and only that,
okay, so what I've done here is essentially define
a schema. The next thing that is important to know
is that we are going to be saving this row based
on a key. This is important As this is how we are
going to be retrieving our data with queries later
on. Okay. So for example, if my UU ID for this
row looks like this, and I can save it, the only
way I can find it is by searching for this key,
and the whole data row will be returned. This
key is also what is known as a partition key.
Because our no SQL database is a distributed
database, it means our data can be sold on
loads and loads of different nodes. So if two
rows had the same partition key, they will be
stored together on one note, and when we query
for that key, they will both return. Got it.
Good. Now let's use it in practice with an example
in which we are going to be storing books in a
tabular database. So now that we have created the
database and has access to us, let's go ahead and
create our first table. To do this, I'm just
going to double click on the database itself,
it should take you to this page in which you
will see the key spaces associated with this
database. At the moment, there is one as we only
created one key space called Tabular. Great.
So now I'm going to do this part using the CPU
or console. So as we know, tabular databases
organize data in rows and columns. Okay, so
that's what we're going to be doing, we're
going to be building a table with rows and columns
to store some data using C QL, or Cassandra query
language. The first thing I'm going to do is use
a command in order to get our key space. So to do
this, I'm going to enter the following command, it
is called describe key spaces. And if I hit that,
you will see all the key spaces associated with my
database, you will also see that tabular is right
here. Just to make sure we are all on the same
page, it keyspace is simply a word for a logical
grouping of tables. So now that we can see our
tabular key space, let's actually get to using it,
I can use it using the following command, use
Tabular. And just hit enter. Don't forget to
put the semicolon at the end. Okay, so now you'll
see that I'm actually in the tabular key space,
I'm inside the key space, I now want to create a
table inside the key space. And I'm going to use
the following SQL command to do so I'm going to
write CREATE TABLE if not exists, okay. So that is
something you're going to need to create a table
in your key space. And I'm going to call the table
books. Now, I'm going to actually define what goes
into my table as well. I'm going to define what it
is I want to put into my table and what type it
is. Okay. So for example, if I choose to put in a
book ID, and then also going to state that this
is a unique identifier. Okay, so from now on,
I can only use Universally Unique Identifiers, or
UU ID as the book ID. For those of you who don't
know what a UU ID is, it is a 128 bit label useful
information in computer systems, I will show you
the structure of it as well as what it looks like
when we get to using it later on. Next, I'm also
going to say that my table of books is going to
have an author and the author. So whatever value
I have as the author is going to be text, okay,
so a string. In other words, we're also going
to have a title, which is going to be texts a
year, which is going to be an integer. Okay,
so a full number, we're going to have categories,
which is a set up texts. Okay. So once again,
I will show you what that looks like we're going
to have multiple categories. Or in other words,
it's going to be a set of texts. And I'm also
going to have added, which is going to be a
timestamp I have defined added to be a time stamp.
So timestamp is also a type in C QL. And finally,
we're going to have a primary key. A primary key
in basic terms is how we're going to search for
a book in our table. Okay, so imagine our table
has hundreds and hundreds of books. We can filter
through the table, we can search through the
table by the book ID, thanks to this primary key
right here. The book ID that I've passed through
into the primary key is also the partition
key that we discussed earlier in the introduction.
Okay, so I'm putting in a partition key
into the primary key. Great, and we're just gonna
close that off and don't forget the semicolon and
press enter. And there we go, we have now created
our very fast, super simple table using CQ L, just
to make sure that has worked, I'm just going to
use the command describe key space Tabular. So the
time I'm picking out the precise key space, and
putting the semicolon and then just hitting Enter,
and there we go, we can see that our table
has been created, okay with the book ID
added author categories set, and yeah, wonderful.
So now that we have finished our table,
we have created our table, let's actually get
to putting things into our table. To do this,
I'm going to use the command insert into. So
I'm going to use Insert into that is a command
that we're going to use to insert data into our
books table. So I'm just gonna write the word
books. And then once again, I'm just going to
put in a book ID and author, a title a year,
the categories that are belongs to and added and
just click enter. The next thing we're going to do
is actually add the values. So we didn't actually
finish off this command, there's no semicolon,
so we did not finish off this command, we're just
making a new line so it's more readable. And I'm
just going to put some values into our books.
So I'm just going to open up the parenthesis,
and I'm actually going to create a
unique identifier. So this is a function,
I'm going to call this so that it creates
a universally unique identifier for me.
The next thing I'm going to do is write a string
of Bobby Brown as we defined author as text. So
this needs to be text and needs to be a string.
And then we're also going to give it a title,
which is also text, it is a string. So I'm going
to put dealing with tables. The next is year,
which we defined as an integer. So I'm just
going to put 1999, and then categories,
which is a set of texts. So to do this, I'm just
going to open up some curly braces this time.
And I'm going to put the string of programming and
the string of computers. This is because I defined
categories as a set of text. So I can only put
text into this set. Okay. And finally, once again,
I'm going to call a function, the function is
called to timestamp. And I'm going to open up
my parenthesis, and I'm just going to put an
another function is called now I'm going to call
it, this will essentially create a timestamp
with this very second. Okay, so timestamp of
this very second that I'm going to put into my
table. I'm just gonna close all this off, and
finish it off with some semi colons, because I'm
done with this command now, and just click enter.
Wonderful. So now let's see if that has worked.
I'm going to use the command select all.
So this little asterix means all from our table
called books. So we have chosen to call the table
books. So that's what I'm using the word books
here, and then let's get our semicolon and just
click enter. and wonderful. Here is
our table, we have created a table,
we've put some data into our table. Let's
have a look. Here, you will see the UU ID
has been generated. This is the structure of
universal, unique identifier that looks wonderful.
Next, we've got added. Okay, so this is the
function that I wrote to timestamp. Now, if I use
the function, today's timestamp down to the second
has been used to populate this cell right there.
And next we have the author of Bobby Brown, the
categories and the title dealing with tables,
as well as the year which is an integer. Great. So
we've created one row in our table, let's get to
adding a nother row into our table. So to do this,
once again, I'm going to use the command insert
into again, I'm going to pick out the table that
I created earlier, which I chose to call books.
And I'm going to say that into this row,
I'm going to put in a book ID, an author,
a title a year categories and add it okay and
then the values that I want for these cells
are going to be once again I'm going to use the
UU ID function to create a universally unique
identifier for me. I'm also going to put a
string of let's put Andrea Agnes as the author
for the title. I'm just going to put the moon as
the title of my book, and for the year I'm going
to put 2001 is an integer, so not a string,
that categories, I'm going to put space and
non fiction, non fiction like so. And then
added. Once again, I'm going to use the to
timestamp and pass through now and
call it. Okay, so there we have it.
Once again, I'm just going to close that off,
and then use a semicolon to finish this command
and hit enter. Wonderful. So now if we
look at everything in our books table,
so I'm just going to use the command to select
all books, oops, we didn't use the semicolon,
select all books. Select all from books, apologies
select all from books is the command we need.
Wonderful, we can see now that two rows
exists on our table that we created. Great,
this is looking really good. As you can see, a
new unique identifier has been generated a new
timestamp, the author name, some categories,
a title, and the year as an integer. Correct.
Now what if I just want to
select one thing from our table?
Well, as we mentioned, we know that we can
use a primary key to the book ID to do this.
So let's go ahead and try do that. I'm going
to use the command select all. So once again,
select and then we use the little star or Asterix
from books. And I'm just gonna hit enter. So I'm
not gonna close up this command yet. And I'm
gonna use the command where and then use book ID
equals. So I've chosen book ID for myself. I've
called it book ID. And I'm just going to select a
unique identifier. Let's select this one. So what
do we expect to return if we run this command?
Correct? That is correct. We are now getting
one item from our table. This because we chose
to select an item by its unique identifier.
Okay, so there we go. We have now successfully
picked out one item from our table using the
book ID, or in other words, the primary key.
So we have now seen how we can pick out one item
from a table. However, how can we filter out
multiple items from a table? Well, to do this,
we're going to work with partitions. So let's make
a new table for this. I'm just going to refresh my
page, you can actually also use the clear command,
instead of refreshing the page. If you want to
clear all of this, it's up to you. So once again,
this is going to be some great repetition for
you some great muscle memory practice. First off,
let's actually get to listing out all the key
spaces using the describe key Space Command.
There we go, we can see the key space that
we want the tabular key space, I'm going to
use the command use tabular in order to pick out
the key space that we want. Next, let's actually
get to creating a table in the tabular key space.
Okay, so we have one table already called books,
I'm going to create a nother table this time.
So the command you need for this is create
table if not exists, and then we're going to
choose to call our table restaurant by country.
Okay, so I've chosen to call my table that as
you can choose to call your table, whatever you
wish. And now, in my table, well, I'm going to
decide that I want to have the following columns,
I'm going to have the country which I'm going to
define as text. Next we're going to have cuisine,
which I'm also going to define as text a URL,
which again is going to be some text. And now
I'm going to have a primary key. So from our
previous lesson, we know that we can search for
something in a table by its primary key, I'm going
to choose to search by the country. The country
is actually the partition key we refer to in the
explainer okay. So, we have a primary key command
and we are passing through where we want the
partition key to be if that makes sense. So, what
I have done is chosen one of the table columns
here I have chosen country to be my partition
key and I have passed that into the primary key
like so. So now also what is happening is that
all my data from now on is going to be distributed
in my database based on the value of country. Now,
the other values here that I have put so name
and URL are What we call clustering keys. So what
this means is that when I search for data based on
the partition key, so in this case, it's country,
I can make it come back in descending order, and
URL in ascending order. Okay, so there we go,
let's go ahead and run that command, not
forgetting the semicolon. And there we go.
Next is actually insert some data into this table.
So just like before, I'm going to use the Insert
to command. And I'm going to insert into the table
that I have chosen to call restaurant by country,
going to open up some parenthesis, and I'm going
to say that I want to put in a country a name,
a cuisine, a URL, and I'm just going to close that
off, and then start a new line with the values.
So open up the parenthesis again, and I'm going
to put the string of Poland the name, I'm going
to put VAs ska, catch ma as a string. And then the
cuisine, I'm also going to put some text for this,
I'm going to put traditional as a string, and
then the URL once again, this is a string,
I'm going to put w w.kajima.pl. And close that
off and for the semicolon, and click enter. And
wonderful, I'm just going to insert a another
row while we are here. So once again, insert into
my table name is restaurant by country, I'm
going to open a parenthesis to say what exactly
I want to put in this row, I'm going to put in
a country and name a cuisine and a URL. And in
the next slide, I'm going to put the values this
time, let's put Singapore and I'm going to put
the shark as a string, this is going to be
American food as a string. And the URL is
going to be W W dot shack dot S, G, no, close
that off. And wonderful. Hit enter. Great.
We can also do a third one. So I'm just going
to actually press up this time, we will just
bring back the last line. And for the values, I'm
just going to replace that with United Kingdom.
And for this one, let's put the red rose.
And I'm going to put pub as the cuisine.
And as the URL. Let's just put red rose.co.uk.
and wonderful. So now click enter. And great.
Let's check if that has worked. So I'm
going to use the select command this time,
Select All. So the Asterix is all from restaurant
by country, because that is the table name.
I want to get everything from the table. Oops,
nice post I semicolon. And great. There is our
table. This is looking good. And once again,
let's try and get in one thing from the table.
So select all from restaurant by countries of the
table name where the country equals the string
Singapore. Okay. And that just puts in semi colons
and hit enter. And that should return back the
singular restaurant. So the shark because that
has the partition key of Singapore. Wonderful.
Now, what do you think happens if we add another
row that also has the country Singapore? Well,
let's check it out. For this part, I'm going
to involve you I'm going to break to an
exercise. So what I want you to do is actually
add a nother line. So now the road to our table
that has the country Singapore, the name of
the restaurant, the heart, the URL www.hud.sg
and cuisine Lebanese, okay, so go ahead and add
one row to our existing table. But before we do
that, I'm going to ask you to refresh the page. So
go ahead and click that. And wonderful. Go ahead.
I'm going to pause here while you have a go at
doing this yourself before we carry on together.
Okay, so first things first you can of course
is the describe key spaces command to list out
all the key spaces in your database. Or you
can just go straight to it if you know which
key space You want to use. So I'm going to choose
Use tabular, just like Sir, making sure that I am
in the tabular key space. Next, I'm going to
essentially insert a row into the table restaurant
by country. So I'm going to do so like so.
First things first, I'm going to use the Insert
into command. And I'm going to insert into rest.
Durrant by country, just like so because that
is the name of our table, I'm going to insert
a country, I'm also going to insert a name, I'm
going to insert some cuisine and a viewer L. Okay.
So that's what I'm going to do. And I'm just going
to make a new line. So don't put the semicolon yet
insert into restaurant by country. And then I'm
going to put in values. And the values are going
to be a string of Singapore. And then the name we
said is going to be the heart. The URL is going
to be WWE dot heart dot S, G. And the cuisine,
which is the one we miss, I'm just going to
go back. It's going to be Lebanese, Lebanese.
Okay, so let's have a look. Make sure
that it's all correct. Okay, great. And
hit Enter. So now we have a look at everything.
So select everything from restaurant by country
that we go, you will see that line has been added,
a new row has been added. So now if we do select
everything from restaurant, we could actually
just press up. And then we go where, and I'm
going to get the partition key. So country equals
Singapore, what do you expect will happen? Tada,
we get back the two restaurants that are in
Singapore. Wonderful. So that is essentially
how you'd group data together in your
table and retrieve that group data back.
Now it's time to move on and look at document
database types, document or document oriented
database types are arguably one of the easiest
types to do. This is because they require no
schema. So before in the tabular database, we had
to define the columns that made up our table. With
this, we don't have to do any of that. As long
as our data comes as an object, it's fine. The
objects are made up of keys and values look like
this. So this is an example of perhaps an item
you might find in a to do list. So here you have
an object which I have given an ID with a zero,
a title with fixed bike as a string description
with a string and done which I have in this case,
given a Boolean that is not strict. The values
can be strings, numbers, Boolean arrays,
or even objects themselves. This is called JSON,
or JavaScript Object Notation, and is the most
popular format for document database types. Now,
a group of documents is called a collection. So we
will not be using the word tables anymore. It has
been replaced by collections. So keep that in mind
moving forward. So what are we waiting for? Let's
get to it. In this next section, I'm going to
make a collection of to do items using a document
API. Now for those of you who haven't heard of the
term API, let's do a quick crash course first. And
API stands for Application Programming Interface.
They allow for technologies to essentially
talk with each other and are essential to
serve the services we rely on today. They are
behind most apps we use on a day to day basis.
And they can shape information paths between one
technology to another. And they connect things
such as our cars, purchase pens, or anything
really, to the internet. API's are everywhere.
As a developer, you might use the Twitter
API to get like tweets on your site, a Map
API that will allow us to get data from a third
party to use a new delivery app we are building
or even use them in a two way stream to get
post or delete data from a customer relationship
management system. For example. There's a reason
why these words are popping up. And let's go into
why. In this next section, you're going to be
seeing these words I'm using them to communicate
with the database you make. In this context.
They are called HTTP request message. That's
the most common are the get request, post
request, PUT request and delete request.
There are others too. But for the sake of the
tutorial, these are the ones you need to know.
Get essentially gets data. And that's all it does.
So imagine you have a client or another word, your
computer and a server, you are on your computer.
And the URL, which is where you want to get your
data from is on a server, the client. So once
again, your computer sends an HTTP get request
to the server to retrieve the data we want. So
here we have a get request or a visualization of
a get request, the client is requesting the server
gives it the necessary resources we need. Then,
after the server has sent the response, so request
and response, we say that we've got it. Thank you.
After the server sends a response, it closes
something called a TCP or transmission control
protocol connection. We also have a POST requests
and put requests. So here we have a visualization
of how the request would work with post requests.
So simply sending something to the server.
And with the PUT request, which are the same,
we are sending something to the server. But
essentially to edit something or override it,
we will go into this in the next section. And
of course, a delete request to a delete request
will essentially delete something that is pointed
to an idea or endpoint. So to get interacting with
my data, you will see these different endpoints,
simply put an endpoint is where a
resource lips. So with this endpoint here,
forward slash burgers, I will get all
my burgers, I can also create a burger
to the same endpoint. To create a burger. However,
I use the post haich TT method. As we discussed,
I can also edit a singular burger, also, as
we discussed. And of course, we have delete,
which you guessed it will delete a singular
burger if we provide the end points with the ID.
Okay, so hopefully, this theoretical example
has made sense, let's get to using our knowledge
in our project. Okay, the first thing we're
going to do is actually create a new key space,
I'm going to call this key space document, I'm
just going to go here and save it. There we go.
Okay, so now we've got two key spaces, I'm going
to keep the workload separate. So one for tabular,
and for document, because we're going to
be working with document types in this
section. So to do this, I'm going to choose to
connect to my database using the Document API.
However, before we do that, we're
gonna have to get a token in order
to communicate with our database. So to
do this, I'm just going to go to settings.
And then under Application tokens,
organization settings, click that
the role I'm going to select as an admin user,
and I'm going to generate a token. So this is
the token we are going to use, please, of course,
do use your own, I will be deleting this after
this tutorial. So just go ahead and copy that and
make sure to store it somewhere safe. Okay, great.
Now, once you've done that, just go back. And
this time, we're not going to use the SQL console,
we're going to use this connect tab. And we're
going to use the document API to connect to our
database. Okay. So all I'm going to do is launch
swagger. And this will load some swagger Doc's for
us that will be useful in communicating with
our database. Okay, so this is all pre made
for us. There's not much we're gonna have to do,
we're just gonna have to fill out some blanks. The
first thing I'm going to do is actually create
a new empty collection in a namespace. Okay,
so before, as mentioned, we work with tables. Now
we're going to be working in collections. Okay.
So once again, we were working with tables before.
Now we're going to work with collections. So I'm
going to create a new empty collection in the
namespace and just click Try it out. And all I'm
going to do is fill out all of these empty spaces
that have been created for us while We are here is
actually important to note that you can write your
own code for these requests. So at the moment, we
are in a post request, I will be showing you how
to do this in the project portion of this course,
for now, we're just going to make use of this
pre configured UI to help us make these requests.
So all I'm going to do is actually put in my
Cassandra token in here. So that's the one that
we just created. And under the namespace ID, well,
we know that our namespace that we just created,
or in other word, a key space is called document.
So that's what we put in here, document, okay,
not tabular document. And next, we're going to
have to put something in the body of our requests.
Okay, so we're going to have to put in some
JSON with the name of the collection. So all
I'm going to do is choose what I want to call my
collection. And I'm going to choose to call it
my first collection, just like so.
Okay, so you open up some curly braces,
this is how Jason looks, we open up some
curly braces, we put the string of name
as we are prompted to, and the string of my first
collection. Wonderful. So now we can scroll down.
And just click execute, and then wait
for our response. And as you can see,
that has returned with a status code 201. Okay,
status code 201. So that has worked. If you
don't know about service codes, that is a really
handy website, I'm going to show you with all the
status codes that could return, it illustrates
them with little dogs. And it's really easy to
understand, this is something that I use quite
a lot in my day to day, developer life. Okay,
so we have now created a collection called
My first collection, let's carry on,
just going to delete all of this, and cancel
that. And now the next thing I want to do
is put something in our collection, right, so
I'm going to create a new document to do this.
Once again, I'm just going to click Try it out.
And I'm going to fill out all of these spaces.
So once again, it's putting the token that we
just created. Next we need the namespace, or
as it's called on our platform, the key space. So
once again, I'm going to put document and in the
collection ID. Well, the collection that I want to
put this in is called My first collection, because
we just created and in the body in the body, I'm
going to put in my first item into the collection.
And this is what I want it to look like. Okay,
so once again, we have the curly braces about the
string of ID, which I'm going to give it as one,
I'm going to give it the title of make dinner.
And then the description of make dinner to
apologize for breaking my housemates bike. And
done is a Boolean of false. Okay, so this is the
first document I want to put into my collection is
just an object that has some information, okay,
I can make this information, whatever I wish.
So this is what my information looks like.
Let's carry on. I'm just going to click Execute.
And there we go, we get a 201 code. And that
has responded, we also get a response with this,
which is the document ID. So the document,
we just created the one with ID one, the one
about making dinner has this document ID,
this is its identifier in our collection.
Okay, great. Now let's get to using this ID. So
now I'm going to show you how to do two things.
I'm going to show you how to search for everything
in a collection. And I'm going to show you how to
search for one thing in a collection. So let's
start off with the first one faster search for
everything in a collection. To do this, I'm going
to just select search documents in a collection.
And once again, I'm just going to put in the
Cassandra token. Let's click Try it out. I'm
also going to put in the namespace or key
space as it's called on our platform. So I'm
going to put in document for the collection.
I'm simply going to put my first collection,
and then I'm just going to execute it. Okay, so
I'm just going to scroll down and hit execute. And
there we go. We get a status code 200. And
we also get the response body. So that is
responding with all the data in our collection.
At the moment. There's only one item Okay,
so it might be a bit hard to tell you might think
it's just bringing about one item but it's in
fact bring back all the items in our collection.
Great Now I'm going to show you how to pick up
an item based on the document ID. So the thing
we created in the part just previous to this.
So to do this, I'm actually going to use the
document ID. So let's just go ahead and grab that.
And then let's go to get a document.
Once again, let's click Try it out,
I'm going to put any document ID, and then I'm
just going to fill this out. So once again,
the collection I'm looking at, and it's called
My first collection. And then the namespace is
called document and the Cassandra token, well,
we just need to paste that in. And click Execute.
And correct. So we're returning that one item from
our collection. Okay, based by its document I do.
Okay, so now that I've shown you how to create
a collection, add a document to collection,
get all the documents back, and just search for
one document in the collection by document ID,
I'm just going to show you how you would do this
in the project part. So all we're going to do,
or essentially all of that is happening here on
this platform is that we are constructing a URL.
Okay, so every time you fill out a field, you are
constructing this long URL. As you can see here,
we've populated it with a namespace, a collection
and a document ID. So this is exactly what we
will be doing in the project part, we're
going to be making a request to this URL,
however, with authorization. So at the moment,
if I just take this URL, and I paste it in the
browser, you will get a message that says role
an authorized for this operation, missing token.
Okay, there are tools that we can use to help
us if we do want to view this before building
our project, one tool that comes to mind is a
tool called hopscotch that I use quite often.
And then all you would do so I'm just going to
gravitate to hopscotch. And I'm simply just going
to create a new request here. So all I'm going to
do is put in the URL that we just created, making
sure that the method is a get request, okay,
because we are getting the data. And I'm simply
going to put the Cassandra token that we have.
So the one that we've saved the really long one
in the header. So once again, I'm going to get
that token, and first actually going to get x
Cassandra tokens, we can identify it, and then I'm
going to paste my long token. Okay, once again,
make sure that this is a get request because we
are getting data from the database, and Qlik.
Sense. Wonderful. So now we get a status code 200.
And we also get some response, we get the response
body to be the document we have just created.
Great. Before we move on, I'm just going to show
you how to do one more thing. And that is search
for something by a filtered field. So what I can
do, I'm just going to go to search for documents
again. And in here, I'm just going to add a where
string. So this to jog your memory is how we
return all the documents back from a database,
I can also filter out which ones I can filter
them out by title. So for example, I can choose
to filter out to this this syntax for filtering
out, I can choose to filter out by say title.
And anything with the title of make dinner will
be returned back to me. So once again, I'm just
going to do that that is the syntax for filtering
out all of my documents and search for any one
that has the title make dinner, or any multiple
ones that have the title made dinner, and then
click Execute. And anything with the title made
dinner will be returned back to me. Okay, great.
Okay, so now that we have done that tiver a
little exercise. Based on all the learning
that we have done so far, how would you go about
creating a new item to put in our collection?
So at the moment, we have one item in our
collection called My first collection,
I would like to add another. So which
of these do you think I should go to?
That's right, I will need to make a post request
to this URL, and replace namespaced ID and
collection ID as well as provide my authorization
token. So let's go ahead and do it. I'm just going
to refresh this so we can start a new and click
here. So once again, I'm just gonna click here
to try it out. Under the Cassandra token, I'm
just going to put in my token, the namespace
ID or as we know the key space ID is called
document and then the collection ID is called My
first collection. And now we need to create our
document. So I'm going to create an object for
this, I could simply just have an ID like so let's
give it the ID of two, and then a description.
And then make it clean dishes after dinner.
And if I executed that, that would work.
However, I have chosen to keep all my objects the
same, that is a personal choice. So let's go ahead
and add a title. I'm going to make the same title
that I did last time, and I will show you why. So
there we go, title description, and then done, I'm
going to give it the value of false, that does not
need to be in quotation marks, that is a Boolean
value that I'm assigning to the property done.
Okay, so now if I click Execute, we get a 201 code
with the response body that has come back with the
document ID for this document right here. Okay,
so we've added one more item, I'm just going to
add a another item, let's make this ID 10. Let's
give it a different title. So fixed shoes. And
take choose to fixed with done false. And
once again, I'm just going to execute that.
So what that means is, I now have three items
in my collection called My first collection.
Two of them have the title make dinner, and one
has the title fix shoes. Now, if I wanted to bring
back all the documents, or the title make dinner,
so all of them associated with making dinner,
how would I do this. So once again, three items
in my collection, I only want to bring by two,
and that includes the ones that
have the title make dinner.
That's right, I would have to make a GET request
to this URL. So replace the namespace ID, the
collection ID and provide an authorization token.
So once again, I'm just going to click to try this
out, I'm going to grab the Cassandra token,
the namespace ID I want to look at is called
document or in other words, the keyspace name, the
collection ID I want to look at is called My first
collection. And this is the syntax for
filtering out I want to filter out by title
and want to make sure that that title is equal,
making sure to put this in quotation marks
equal to make dinner, which is case sensitive.
Okay, so that's the syntax. And what do I
expect to come back, I'm actually going to
set the page size, let's just make it Max
20. So if I add more than two, for example,
and I only want to 20. To come back, this is how
I do it. And then I'm just going to click Execute.
And there we go. So now we can see
that two items have come back to us,
this one, this one, and we do not see
the item that has the title fix shoes.
Great. And once again, all we have done is
generated this URL by filling out all of the
above. Okay, so what I am doing is, there we go,
we see the namespace has been replaced, you will
see the collection name has been replaced. And
if we look where well, we are looking for a title
equal to make dinner. And we only want
to bring back Max 20 items. Wonderful.
So I hope you've learned a lot in this section.
Please do pause here, I can't stress enough how
much I recommend pausing here and having a play
around with all the different requests you can
make. So for example, if you want to delete a
document, or update a document to please have
a play around with that, and once you are
done, I will see you in the next section.
In this next section, we are going to look at
the key value databases. They are considered
to be the easiest database type and usually
come looking like this. So you have a key
column and then you have a value column. You can
actually have as many value columns as you wish.
The important thing here is that we can retrieve
data back to us. So an entire row by the key as
that is the identifier in this case. Let's
have a quick look at an example of a key
value database and how to make one next Okay, so
I'm going to click here and just add key value,
and click save. Okay, great. So we can now see
another key space has been added. Now, this time,
I'm going to use Graph QL, just as a little
bit of something different in order to create
our key value table. Okay, so this time, I'm
going to choose to connect using the Graph QL API,
just purely because we've already worked with
the document API. So I'm going to click here,
and just launch the Graph QL playground, just like
so. Now, the first thing we need to do when we are
here is to create a new table. So first off, I'm
actually going to put in my Kasandra tokens are
able to communicate with my database. So I'm
just going to grab it, just like so. And now
you should be able to see the documents populate
with all the queries or mutations that we can do.
So as I said, I want to create a table. So
let's go ahead and do that. This is a mutation
as it's under the mutations tab. And to create
a table, just going to write create, table,
and EZ Pass through the following things. So
a keyspace name, a table named partition keys,
and values. So the key space name, I'm just going
to put this on a new line. Well, we know that the
key space name is key value, as we've just created
it. Now the next thing we need to actually do is
give our table a name. So I'm going to call this
shop inventory just like so. And the partition
keys. Now, if you remember from the first section,
our partition keys is essentially the key that we
want to filter our table by or search for items
in our table by and it says here that this needs
to be an array. So that's what we're going to do,
we're making an array. And then what do we want
our partition key to be, I'm going to give it the
name of Ki. And I'm also going to define the types
that it takes. So I'm just going to put type,
like so. And I'm going to pass through basic text.
Great. So we have our key space name, we have
our table name, we have our partition keys. Next,
let's put in the values. As you will see, these
all have a bank after them. So they are required
values is not required, but we're going to need
it for our table. So once again, I'm just going
to put a comma and put in values. And this needs
to be an array. So I'm going to open up the array,
and I only want another one column. So at the
moment, we've got one column, which is a key.
The next column I want to have is values. So
I'm going to name this value. And once again,
I'm just going to give this the type of basic
text, just like set. And if we click here,
wonderful, we have created our table. Great.
So we've created our table, the next thing
I'm going to do is add keys and values to our
table. So I'm just going to go ahead and delete
this. And instead of having a Graph QL schema,
I'm going to have Graph QL forward slash,
and I'm just going to put in the key space. So
key value, just like sir. and wonderful. So now
we're in the key space key value, I'm going to
use another mutation to see who the mutations and
queries have changed because I can do a bunch
of other stuff. I'm going to use the Insert
shop inventory. Okay, so that is what I'm going
to do and start mutation as this is a mutation.
And I'm just going to say shop,
insert shop inventory, just like so. And I'm
going to use this to insert items into my table.
So I need to open up some parenthesis, and then
in here, well, I want to pass through a value.
And that's going to have my key. So what
key can we give this I'm just going to put
an A string as we said it needs to be text.
And I'm just going to choose to give it this
key. So this identifier just like so. And then the
value of let's have beans. So what I'm saying with
this code is that I want to put in this row into
my table that I have just created and the row will
have the key of this The value of beans, meaning
that if I want to search for beans in my table,
I would use this identifier. Okay,
so I'm just going to also have to
return something. So we know this works.
So I'm just going to return the key and the
value. Click here. Wonderful. So now we know
that we have inserted this one item into our
shop inventory into our table that we have called
shop inventory. Let's just add another item. So
I'm just going to make this random once again.
And then another item we can put in his shell.
And just click Yeah. Great. So now I'm going
to actually retrieve this data. But first off,
I just want to show you what this looks like if we
use the sequel console. Okay, so I'm going to go
back here. And under the secure console, well, I
am just going to write, use key value, because we
need to get the key space. And once we are here,
I'm going to use the command describe table.
Shop inventory. Okay, so we can see here, we have
added that table, that table exists and exists
in the keyspace key value. And now if I
want to grab everything from the table,
well, hopefully you remember this from the first
lesson, select all this essentially means all
from shop inventory, making sure that I spelt it
correctly inventory. And there we go. We have a
table that has a key and a value. And we can find
any item in our table. So any row by the partition
key or the key right here. Great. Okay. So
hopefully, you can see how we can make tables
using the key and value approach. Just while
we're here, I'm going to show you how to retrieve
all the data from our table using Graph QL as
well, just in case you are not familiar with
Graph QL. This time, I'm going to have to have a
query. So I'm going to write a query just like so.
And I'm going to look in the shop inventory.
Okay, so I'm looking in the shop inventory. And
what do I want to return? Well, if I just
want everything, then I would simply put
values, key value, and click enter. And there we
go. We are getting all the items from our shop
inventory table. Okay, so if you want to use this
in the project, and you want to get all the items
from your shop inventory, this is the
query that you would use. Wonderful.
Okay, before we move on, I'm just going to do a
little exercise to see if you've remembered what
we've learned. So I'm just going to get rid of
this. If I want to add one more item into the shop
inventory. How would I do this? And what two
things do I need to check? Well, first off,
we need to check the we're in the correct URL.
Okay, so we need to make sure that the URL is
pointing to the key space. In this case, its key
value, because that is what I call my key space.
And that I also have my Cassandra token in the
header. Okay, so those are the two things you
need to check. And once you have checked that
we can write a mutation, okay, not a query,
a query essentially retrieves back data. And a
mutation adds data deletes data, or edits data.
So for this, because we are adding a new item
into our shop inventory, I need to write a
mutation. And that mutation is insert shop
inventory, because I'm inserting into the
table called shop inventory. Okay. And what do we
need to put in here? Well, we need the values of
key and value. And what are we going to have the
key well, at once again, I'm just gonna put in a
random string like that as an identifier.
And the value this time I'm going to put,
I don't know, Coca Cola. Okay, great. And just
to check this as work, I'm going to return the
values of key and value. I could technically just
return one, it is up to you, and just click here.
So now because that has returned, we know that has
worked. Brilliant. Now, how do you think and this
is something we haven't covered? So this is going
to require you to have a little bit of a think
based on what I've told you. How do you think
we would delete an item from the shop in entry.
Well, that's right. Because we are changing the
data, we're going to have to find a mutation
that will delete from our shop inventory. And
because we find stuff by the partition key,
so this, we are probably going to have to delete
an item by searching for this key right here. So
let's check it out. So I know this is going to
be a mutation. And I can also look in the docs
to find the Delete shop inventory mutation to
help me out. So that is a mutation that I need
delete shop inventory, and I'm just
gonna pass through the values of
key, I'm just gonna grab this one right here,
I'm just going to return the value of key.
Okay, and that should have worked. Let's go have a
look here. And once again, I'm just going to chop
list out everything in my shop inventory. And
amazing. So we added the Coca Cola, and then we
deleted the Coca Cola to great. Now, if I was
to say try delete something by the value, so
let's go ahead and put sham and then just return
the value, we will get an error. This is because
we cannot delete by the value we have to delete
or the primary key, which we set to be the key.
Okay, wonderful. So I hope you've learned a lot
in this section. And I'll see you in the next one.
In this next section, we are going to look at
Graph databases. Graph databases are a great
way to store data that has relationships between
other pieces of data, or in other words, notes.
Each node is connected by an edge to represent
this relationship. Think for example, your friends
on social media, he was you and here are three of
your friends. So you and your friends are nerds.
And the connection you have is represented by this
line, or as we are going to call it from now on an
edge. Easy, right? But wait, your friends can also
be friends with each other. So how do we represent
that? Well, by adding more edges to represent
the relationships, and as your friendship circle
expands, the more complex it can get. So that is
the simple idea behind how graph databases work.
Let's see it in action. In this section, we
will be doing an overview of an already existing
demographic database. The GitHub repository
for following along will be given to you in the
description below. So once it gets to that, please
go ahead and find it below. Okay, so this time,
we are not going to be using the datasets Astra
interface, we're going to be using the data stacks
enterprise graph. Okay, so let's go to it. For
this part, you're going to have to have Docker
installed. So please go ahead and download
Docker if you don't have it already installed
onto your machines. Okay, so once you have it
installed, it should look something like this.
All you need to do when you're here is just
click the settings and make sure that the
CPU and the memory, the swap and the disk
image size are all around about these levels.
Okay, so that is what you need to
do. Make sure that you have at least
two CPUs. So here you see eight,
and at least three gigabytes or RAM.
So these are the settings you need. Once you have
them. Let's carry on. And once you have that done,
I'm just going to ask you to get up your
terminal. And then in whatever directory you wish,
please write the following command. So please
go ahead and write the command Docker network,
create a graph and click enter. So what you
should have is this long ID right here. Okay, so
once you have that we are now ready to carry
on. This is your identifier for the graph.
The next thing I'm going to ask you
to do is clone this directory. So
this is directory I will be putting at the
bottom in the description. So just clone
the data stacks tabs workshop
introduction to no SQL and click enter.
Now I already have that in here. So I'm just going
to go into the directory, CD workshop introduction
to no SQL and once we are in here We are free to
start the container. So what I'm going to do is
Docker compose up D, and then wait for that to
open up empty localhost 9091. So this will take a
while please feel free to pause here have a break.
Let's get back to it once all of this is complete.
Okay, great. And now let's go ahead and
visit localhost 9091. Okay, so this is an
example from data size itself, please feel
free to use it and adapt it as you wish.
And there we go. So this is what you should
see here is the example that is given
to us from data stocks. Let's go ahead and first
check our connections. So I'm just going to click
here and on connections, it's going to click
on this one right here. And just make sure
that this is on DSC. Okay, so this
essentially is pointing to our local
Cassandra. So once that is done, let's test it
out. And great, so we are connected successfully.
Let's carry on. Now, let's go back to here
and just click on this example one, like so.
Now, you will see that you're prompted to create
a graph. So let's go ahead and create our first
graph. I'm just going to keep it as to do tutorial
graph like so. So just leaving all the default
settings. Okay, and I'm just going to click
Create. Wonderful, our first graph is now created.
Now if you move down here, you will see a language
called Gremlin. Okay, this is the language that
we are going to use for this tutorial, it is
essentially another query language. Okay, so
we've looked at SQL, we've looked at C QL. And now
we have Gremlin it is a graph traversal language,
okay, and it has been developed by Apache
TinkerPop of the Apache Software Foundation.
With this language, we are essentially creating
schema, okay, so just like we have been doing,
you will see here that we are adding a schema
called God. And we are giving a partition key.
In this case, it's going to be the name, which is
some text, and it also has a property, which is
age, which is an integer, and we are creating it,
we are also creating a demigod which has the same
partition, a human again, which has a partition
key of name, a monster, a location and a Titan.
Okay, so here we have the code in order for us to
essentially create our first graph, all about gods
and demigods and monsters. So I'm just going to
click here to run this. So run this in real time.
And wonderful, that has been a success. So,
now, if we look down to here, you will see
some more code again in the language Gremlin.
So just like we created labels here of God,
demigod human monster, we have now also included
edges. So these edges are essentially how each
one is going to be related. So this edge is called
Father. So this is going to show us a relationship
of father and son or daughter. And then
also we have mother and brother, too.
And it will also give us the direction. So a god
is essentially the father of a demigod, but also
can be the father of a god if someone is a Titan.
Okay, so that is how that looks. Let's carry on.
If we move down, we can see more edge labels.
Okay, so we can also write a relationship
of who's battled who, as well as father and
brother, we can also do where someone lives,
or if someone's a pet, and so on. And finally,
we can actually add items to our graph.
So this is how you would add some items into a
graph. So for example, here we are adding Saturn,
we are saying this is a Titan, we are giving it
the property name of Saturn and we are giving an
age of 10,000 and so on. And we do this
for all these other items as well. Okay.
So there we go, we are defining the items and we
are defining the relationships between the items,
or in other words, the edges between the nodes.
And finally, we can have a table of what this
looks like as well. So here we can see this in
table format. But what is more interesting is
the graph view. So this is essentially what our
information looks like once it has been graphed
out with nodes and edges. So the edges symbolize
the relationship. So if you have a deeper look at
this, we can actually click on these, and it will
give us more information. So for example, this
is a monster of Hydra, you will see the name it
has as Hydra, you also see as the labor monster,
and by its node, you will see that it's battled
the monster service. Okay, so there we go. This
is a great example of how graphs can really
illustrate information and an amazing way.
Now, this has been a lot shorter than the other
tutorials. This is because I just wanted to
show you how you can work with graph databases,
it will involve learning the Gremlin language,
but I think this is a good place to start in order
to get your head around it. So I'm going to leave
this information to you, I'm going to put the
link in the description. And please do have a
go at getting this up yourselves and having a
play around with it as well. So if we want to
add one more thing into our database, we can do
it right here. And just don't forget to run it.
So now because there isn't much of an exercise
here, I'm just going to give you a pop
quiz. When working with graphs, what
would these be called. So these right
here that I'm putting out this little red
guy right here, these monsters, and this god.
These will be called nodes. And what connects
the nodes? That's right edges. So once again,
these are the edges. And if we actually
gravitate over them in this UI, it will
give us the relationship between each note. Okay,
so as we can see here, we have a little house,
the location is the sky. And then this is where
Jupiter lives because he loves the fresh breezes.
Wonderful. Okay, so I think we are done
with looking at graphs to power this down,
I'm just going to run a command, it's going to be
Docker compose down, and just hit enter. Great. So
that is all four of the database types. I think
we're now ready to move on with some projects.
Now that we have covered the four main database
types, I want to quickly talk to you about the
multi bottle type. In this course, let's
actually recap what we've done. Well,
we created a database right and in it, we stored
the key value pairs as for the first tutorial,
after that we stored Jason document in
Astra DB as per the document type tutorial.
We then store data in tables as per the tabular
tutorial, section two. And finally, we stored
graph data. So that's a variety of different data
models, all stored in one place by the graph one.
All of this is possible because Astra DB
is actually a multi model, no SQL database,
you can use the same database to store
a variety of data models. What is cool
about this is that you also only need to learn
and maintain one database which makes your job
easier. Learn one database and use
it to solve many different problems.
Okay, wonderful. Now, hopefully through the
explanations, examples, and exercises you are
now feeling a lot more confident is not only
understanding the different types of no SQL
database types, but also how to use them. If
not, don't worry, I have two short term real
life projects that we're going to build in order
to show you how you would interact with your
databases when building JavaScript projects.
By using a data API gateway like Stargate IO,
Cassandra and Astra D view, developers can opt to
use a Graph QL rest or schemaless JSON document
API as an alternative to C QL. Let's do it.
Okay, and let's get to it. In this project,
I'm gonna be showing you how to use the document
type as well as the document API. In order to
create up first project. This project is going
to be a app which will show you all your favorite
burger restaurants. Okay, so let's get to it. I've
actually started with a fresh board. So you will
notice there are no key spaces, and we're going
to have to go ahead and create our database again.
So I'm just going to go here, and let's call our
database project work and our keyspace Bogguss.
And then once again, I'm just going to have to
create the area that I'm in and create a database.
Wonderful. So you will see my database is
being created and you will see the status is
pending and I'm just going to wait for that to be
active so that I can go ahead and start using it.
And wonderful, the status is now active, let's
go ahead and use our database. So to do this,
I'm just going to double click in here, and
you will see the key space name of bagus. Now,
let's get to adding some data. I'm going to
do this thanks to the document API as stated.
So first off, we need to create a token. So I'm
just going to click in here. And the role I'm
going to choose is admin user. And I'm just going
to create a token. Once again, please make sure to
keep this token safe, I would strongly recommend
saving it somewhere useful. Okay. So once we have
that, let's go back to this documentation right
here. Let's go ahead and launch the Swagger UI.
So I'm just going to go ahead and click that.
And these should populate in front of you.
So we have a lot of options here. And a lot of
endpoints. If you remember from the tutorial, the
one I need first is this one right? Here, we need
to create a collection in order to store our data.
So I'm just going to go ahead and click that and
click Try it out. Once again, I'm just going to
paste the Cassandra token in here so that we can
essentially communicate with the database. And
then let's go ahead and choose the namespace. Or
in other words, the key space, we want to create
our collection in as we have just created it, this
is fresh in my mind. And I know that the keyspace
name is bogus. Wonderful. And in here, we just
have to pass through an object that has the name.
And then whatever we want to call our collection.
So I'm going to call this burger info.
Just like so. And I'm just gonna click Execute.
And great, we get a 201 code, we've made a request
to this URL with our new authorization token. And
the status code we got back was 201. Or in other
words, let's have a look at the status docs again.
Or in other words, to have one for created.
Great. So now that we have created our collection,
what's the next thing we need to do, the next
thing we need to do is add some documents into
the collection. So I'm going to go ahead
and do it by selecting this one right here.
It is a post request to this URL. So once
again, I'm going to choose to try it out.
I'm going to paste in my Cassandra token, the
namespace or the key space ID that we want to
communicate with is called burgers. The collection
ID we just created is called burger info.
And then the body is essentially the document
that we want to put into our burger info. So
I'm going to choose my document to look like
this. I'm going to give each restaurant a name.
So for example, Bob's Burgers.
So that is a string I've chosen
to give it the string of Bob's Burgers.
I'm also going to give it a description
and I'm going to say tasty burgers
from a fictional character from TV, so we've got
the name, we've got description, we can also have
ingredients and we can do this if we wish as an
array. So in here I'm going to put a patty to beef
patty. I'm also going to put tomato
let's also put some cucumber, some lettuce
and some cheese. Okay, so those are my
ingredients. I don't only have to put
strings in here. I can also put an array
of strings if I wish. Okay. And one last
thing that I want to show you is okay, we
can also have Boolean I can have visited,
and I can have true. And then I can also visited
have objects within objects. So if I put location,
like so, as a property, I can have an object
as a value. So that is also an option. Let's
go ahead and do that, I'm just going to open up
my objects. And in here, I can have so location,
address. And then have that to be us
string if I wish. So 45, lambda lambda.
Drive, I can also have a, let's do zip code, which
is an integer. So I'm going to make this up. And
then I can also have the web address. So this is
just going to be WW do W dot Bob's burgers.com.
Okay, just like that. So we have a string here,
we have a string here we have an array of strings,
we have a Boolean, we also have an object,
which has an address, a zip code as an integer,
and a web address as a string. Now let's have a
look and see if this is working. We could also
give it a unique ID, we don't want it to
count from zero. So perhaps let's go ahead
and do that. I'm just going to go ahead and
maybe let's start from 340. Why not? Okay,
so now let's execute this. And great. Our
first document has been created. And we also
get a document ID that has been assigned to this
object right here. So we have one, let's go ahead
and add another. So I can just do so from here.
Let's go ID 341. This time, let's go Matilda's.
And Matthews, man hot turn Burger
Joint. And then let's change this
up. They have a tofu patty. Tomatoes,
let's have a pickle. So pickles.
Let's also have some letters. And then we can
have Bri visited I'm going to put as false. And
the location let's change this up. So I'm just
going to put in a random location. Let's put
Denver Avenue SIC code once again, I'm just going
to make this up. And then let's put and progress
and just click Execute. Great. So we have two
documents in our Bulga info collection. Let's
just add two more. So I'm just going to change
the ID again. And then let's have gertrudes place
hipster and gout in the city as the description
and I'm going to have a beef patty. Let's have
perhaps something else here so called Slow
pickles, lettuce and there's cheeseless cheddar.
This is it I'm going to have as truth and the
location. Let's have one or three darling turn.
Drive. Once again, just make up the zip
code. Go through its place.com and just click
Execute. Let's go ahead and just add one more. So
there we go. And then let's have fancy burgers.
A new location for Burger snobs. Some
beef patty? Let's also have a onion
ring in this one. Some pickles some
letters. And let's just have some generic
cheese visited, I'm going to put
out false location, I'm going to put
one, Walter Street. Make this up. And have
and see progress.com and click Execute.
Great. So now we have four bugs in here.
But let's just double check this has worked.
So to get all of our burgers back, I'm going to
search documents in a collection. So I'm just
going to go here, this will be a get request, as
I'm getting the data, I'm just going to paste in
my token right here, I'm going to look in burgers.
That is the I quote my keyspace. The collection ID
is called burger info. And then I'm going to say
that, I'm going to have a max of 20, come back,
and I'm just going to click Execute. And there we
go, we can see all four of our Bogguss coming back
to us. Great. So that is exactly the data that we
need. Now let's get to using this in a project.
So essentially, what I want to do is build
a project in which I'm going to be making a
request to this URL right here and passing through
my authorization token. So let's do it. I'm just
going to go ahead and open up WebStorm.
So I'm going to go my WebStorm project.
And I'm going to say this is a React
project. So let's call this Barger
app, just like so I'm going to use the Create
react app command in order to build out
a React project for me all configured so we
can go. So I'm just going to click Create.
And as you can see, that command has sprung into
action. And I'm essentially just downloading all
the dependencies, fetching all the dependencies
and packages that I need in order to get the
boilerplate for my react projects. Of course,
if you're not using WebStorm, please go ahead
and get to this point as well. All you need
to do is create a project it will directory
using the command MPX create react up. Correct.
So now that we have that, let's get to it.
So as you can see here, the MPX create react
app has essentially populated all this for me
with the following packages and ran these
following scripts. Okay, so these are the
dependencies that have been installed. And
these are the files have come with create
react app. So if I actually run this, I'm just
going to go ahead and click npm start, like so
this is essentially what should show up on
localhost 3000. Okay. So that is something
that you should be seeing right now, if I go
ahead and actually delete all these files,
so I'm actually going to go ahead and just do some
deleting. So here is our app. This is essentially
the spinner that we saw. So you will see here the
spinner is this right here. I'm going to go ahead
and delete all of this like so. If I actually just
go Hello, I'm going to show you how this looks.
Okay, as you can see that is working. So
that is updating. So I'm just going to
delete this for now, I don't need a logo,
so I'm actually going to get rid of that.
I don't like to semicolon. So I'm just
going to delete that. And I like to use
functional expressions. So I'm just changing this
as this is my preference, but you are free to keep
it as as you wish. So there we go. We don't need
the logo. So I'm just going to go ahead and delete
that from this project. Don't need the report by
tools. So I'm going to delete that. Delete anyway,
let's delete the tests as well as we're not
going to be writing tests for this project.
And let's delete this test file. Okay, great. I
don't also need I'm actually going to delete the
CSS file as I'm going to be doing all my CSS in
this index. CSS file. So I'm going to delete this
I'm just going to put all my styling in one file
for this Project. So there we go, there's our
app js file. And if we look in here, we don't need
this as we've just deleted it. We don't need this
as that is now non existent. And once again,
I'm just going to get rid of the semicolons.
Like, so. Okay, wonderful. Let's just check,
we didn't break anything. And this is looking
good. It's good, my console locked up, too. Okay,
so now that we have a blank slate, let's get to
actually getting our data. So to do this, I'm
going to have to create a little mini backend.
So just in the root of my project, so on the
same level as Git ignore, I'm going to create a
new file, just a new file like this, and I'm going
to call it index j, s. Okay. So there we go. This
is essentially going to be my mini backhand in
which I'm going to build a backend using Express.
So first things, first, let's decide
what port we want our backend to run on,
I'm going to say that I want my port to run on
80,000 8000. Sorry. And we're going to have to
install a few dependencies for this, one of them
will be Express. So we're going to use Express for
this project. And use require Express. So I'm
just going to get up my terminal and install
Express like so I'm also going to need
cause Morgane node fetch so we can do
fetching in the backend, and dot EMV for
storing secret variables. Okay, so please
go ahead and just install these dependencies,
and I'll talk you through them as we use them.
Okay, so I'm just going to leave that
to install. And let's go ahead and just
actually use them in the backend of the project.
So require package cause. And then const. Morgan
equals require Morgan, Morgan is actually a
package that we're going to use in order to,
I'm going to show you what it looks like. So
I'm just going to go, Morgan is essentially
going to help us debug the backend better and
make everything a little bit more readable.
So this is the package, if you want to have more
of a look. It's essentially a little logger, that
will give us more information when we use it. And
once we do use it in our project. So once we do
essentially do this, so we're using the package or
storing it as Morgan we've done the same, we then
need to pass tiny into Morgan. Okay. So this is
essentially what is going to let us debug better.
So as you can see, I've got the package, and
I'm storing it under the constant Morgan. And
I'm just going to use Morgan and pass through
tiny so we can use the logger better. Great.
So we've got Morgan, the next thing I
need is a package called node fetch.
And this essentially works sort of similar
to the Fetch API, and will allow me to make
fetch requests on the so just like
that, that's how I'm going to use Fetch.
Just to be sure that everyone is using the
same packages, please be sure to be using
these packages that I have right here, there could
have been updates. So to prevent any issues, just
make sure that these other ones you are using, or
if you're in doubt, please feel free to check out
my GitHub project that I will share with you in
the description of this video below. And finally,
we also need the.in v to.in. The package will
allow us to read secrets from the back as well.
And this is how you would initiate it. Okay. So
all I'm doing is actually getting this from the
documentation. I'm doing this from memory as I've
used these so many times. But if we search here
here we go. As you will see, all I'm doing is
taking this and using it in my project in order
to use the.nv package. Whoops, please spell that
correctly dot CSV. Okay, great. So this is looking
good. Now let's initialize Express. So the package
that I have just imported and stored as Express,
I'm now going to initialize like so. So now if I
use up like this, I can use Morgan tiny in my back
I can also use course, this will essentially
stop me from having any cause issues,
I will show you what I mean by this when we
get to building our app a little bit further.
And then I can also use Express, Jason. Okay. And
this will essentially allow me to read the Jason
in a way that I can use it in the backend. Once
again, I will show you what happens when I don't
use this. Okay, so just make
sure to have all of these,
like so and all this boilerplate done, so we can
start coding. Okay, so please pause here, make a
note of this, I'll make it a little bit bigger, so
you can see everything a little bit clearer. Once
again, things to remember are, please do make sure
index js files in the root of your project. Okay,
so on the same level as package, Jason, and then
this is the boilerplate setup that you need in
order to get going with our backend. So the first
thing I'm going to do is get all the restaurant
data. Okay, that's the first thing
you can do. And I'm going to show you
how. So to do this, and once again, you can
use app like so. So app is essentially what we
saved express as initialized expressed as, and
now I'm not going to use use, I'm going to use
get. And what I'm going to pass through into here
is an endpoint that I'm going to choose. Okay,
I'm going to choose this by myself. I want
to say that if I visit localhost 8000, which
is going to open this up in a new tab, if I
visit localhost 8000, forward slash burgers,
I essentially want the burger data to show up.
Okay, so that's what I'm writing here. By putting
forward slash burgers, I'm deciding that this is
where I want my data to populate. Okay, great.
So that is the first thing I'm going to
do. Before we get going actually, let's
listen out to see if the server's working. So
this I would do it once again, if you use up
this, I'm going to use listen. So not to
use and not get, I'm going to use listen,
I'm going to listen out to port 8000. And
it's all working, I'm just going to
console log out. Server is running on
port, and then whatever the port number is.
Okay, so this is looking good. Let's also
write a script for this because we don't have
at the moment. So I'm just going to go in here
and start front end. So I'm
going to keep that script,
but I'm going to say stop front end needs
to be written in order to start our app. So
our front end, and I'm going to add a new
script. So this time, if I start backend,
like so then I just want to run the backend.
So that's the command to do so. Okay, great.
So let's go ahead, and I'm
going to stop this from running.
I'm going to change the script to start front
end and run it. Okay, so the front end should
have started. And now I'm going to open up a new
tab. Okay, there we go. So that's just running.
Let's go back to our project. And now I'm going
to open up a new tab. So new tab in our terminal.
And this time, I'm just going to run this command
that I have written. So NPM. Run, start back end.
Okay, great. And I'm just going to comment this
out for now. comment this out for now because
we are not using it. And there we go. Okay,
server is running on port 8000. So this is
looking good. Obviously, at the moment, we don't
have anything coming back. So I'm just going to
continue with this. So if we visit this
endpoint, what do we want to do? Well, we
want to fetch the data. So for this, I am actually
just going to don't have a request or a response.
Let's just have it in here for now. And
we might change that later. And then
Okay, actually, let's just get rid of
it. So we'll just have a function a
callback to be precise with passing through
a callback. And then we need to essentially
fetch data from the URL. So if I just save this
as URL for now and make this a little bit smaller,
we essentially want to fetch data from this
URL right here. So I'm just going to copy that,
I'm going to paste it as a string, like so.
Okay, so that's all I have done for now.
Okay, we will be tightening this up. But this
essentially is what this looks like at the moment.
So there's a URL, now I need to make a get this
is a get request. So let's go ahead and do that.
So now it's time to use Fetch. So fetch
takes a URL, okay, which is essentially this.
And we're also going to have to
pass through our Cassandra token Ks,
or our authorization token. So I'm going to do
this along with options. So let's define our
options. So const options like so. And in here,
we know that the method is a get method, okay.
And we also need to pass through some headers.
So the headers that we need to pass through,
we need to accept this like so as a string. And we
also need to pass through the X Cassandra token.
Okay, so we need to pass through essentially
this, just like we are passing it through. Okay,
you will see this is part of the header.
Okay. So essentially what is happening
behind the scenes here, we are now coding out.
So I'm just going to once again as a string
posts, my token. Okay. So now when we make
a fetch, let's just uncomment this out. Now,
when I fetch I am passing through this year,
well, we are fetching data from this URL,
it is a get request. And we are using this in
order to pass through our Cassandra token. Okay,
great. So we are making a fetch, and
this is going to return a promise.
So I then need to chain it with
the then keyword. And the response
is going to be the response. Jason. And this
is also actually going to return a promise.
So we need to chain it again. And this
time, I just want to get the Jason
Okay, so great. Now we do actually need
to pass through a request and response.
So let's just do that now. Okay,
so whatever's coming back to us,
we need to view as JSON and then let's catch
any errors. So I'm just going to catch the
errors by console logging out any errors
that will turn so we can see. Just like so.
Okay, so there we have it. There's a lot of
tidying up to do. But let's first make sure
that this works. Just make sure that is in the
string itself. Cool. So let's give it a whirl.
Now if I visit localhost 8000, forward slash
burgers, this is the endpoint that I have chosen.
Tada, you will see all my four buggers show up.
You will see each object has its own document
ID as well. Great. If you're not seeing it in this
format, it could be because you don't have a Jason
view extension added. This essentially will make
your your JSON much more readable. Okay, so if
you don't have that, please go ahead and add the
extension. Now. This is what it should look like.
Okay, wonderful. So we have our data coming
through. Now let's get it into the front end.
But first, I'm just going to tidy this up
real quick. So we don't need this anymore.
Okay, keep that as it is the URL.
So essentially what we are doing is
Passing through the key space, which is burgers
and passing through the collection name, okay,
so you could save it as separate things and pass
it through. So for example, I could say key space
as the name, focus, and then pass it through into
here with this syntax, like so. So what's gonna go
barbers and then make sure that these are
backticks. So there we go. So that is an option to
if you want to make things I'm sorry, that should
be key. So what do we save this as key space,
key space. So that is an option if you
want to make this more readable, or
you can and this is what I'm going to choose
to do. Because we are not going to be changing
this is pretty much going to stay as it
is, I'm just going to get the whole URL
just like so. And I'm going to save this as a
secret. So I'm just going to go in here. And
once again, on the same level, I'm going to
create a new file, I'm going to call it dot
n fi. Okay. And now I'm going to save
this in here as endpoint. So just
like so. And I'm just going to paste it in here,
just like that. So there we go. And now to access
this right here, I'm going to use process NV and
put, okay, so this wouldn't work if we didn't
have this package and didn't use it
just like so. And now I think we have to
rerun this. Let's just check that out. Okay,
now that seems to be working as it is. Great. So
we've saved our URL as a secret back here. One
other thing that I'm going to save is my Astra
token. Okay, so there we have it. And once
again, I'm just going to save all of this
is going to grab that as it is, and use process.
EMV. And then whatever we call it in our Astra
dot EMV file is what we need to call it here. So
let's say that and I'm just going to paste that
in here like so. Okay. Great. And that seems to be
working just fine. Okay, so we've cleaned this up
a little bit, got a URL, we're passing
through the URL and the options into fetch.
And great, one thing we can do is write
some middleware. So if I write function
not found, and we post you the
request the response and next.
And then in here, if we get a four, four
status, so let's go back to our status dogs.
Okay, so you will see that for four means
not found. So if we get a four of four, well,
then I'm going to get a new error, the error is
going to say, not found, so we're just making
debugging a bit easier with this, we're going
to get the message that says not found, okay,
so that is what we are going to do. And then if
it's none of these, we move to the next function,
which is just an error handler in general, and
it's going to be less specific error. And law.
We're gonna pass through the error to this
error right here. And then request and response.
And this time, if the response if the status code
is whatever the status codes, it's, so wherever it
comes back as or 500. So any error or sorry, any
status code or 500, then I want to send a message.
That is, whatever comes with that status code.
Okay, so there's two ways of doing it. So I'm
just going to show you what this means. Okay,
so now let's get to using it. So once again,
I need to right up use and I'm
going to use the function not found
and I'm also gonna pass through the
function error handler, just like so.
Okay, so what I've written means that if I say
misspelled this URL, if I wrote burgers like that,
I get the message, not found, I get the error
message, not fat. However, if I didn't have this,
so I'm just gonna come on out, and I go
to here. Oops, actually would have this.
See, it just says cannot get burgers, it
doesn't really tell me why it doesn't give me
enough information. However, if it's not found,
so for for iMessage, telling it to show me an
error that says not found, okay. So that is how
we do that. And then any other error, we get a
different error message. So we essentially just
get the error message that goes with these status
codes. But this way, we can be more specific, I
can go pay, you are in the wrong place, buddy.
Hey, we're on their own pace, buddy. Okay, so
cool. It's gonna pull it back to something more
general. Okay, so we are guessing all of our
baggage data. Now let's get to using this in
the front end of our project. So once again,
these are all the packages that I have used,
or the dependencies I've used, just make sure
that you're using the same versions. Okay, great.
Now, let's carry on. So essentially, for my
front end, so we can shut down the backend.
Now, in my front end, I essentially
want to get all the data from
this URL, so we can use it.
So let's go ahead and do that.
To do this, I'm actually going to import a nother
package. So I'm just going to get up my terminal.
And I'm going to install the package Axios. Okay,
this package is essentially going to help you make
the requests and fetch the data. So let's go
ahead and do it, I'm going to write a function
right in here. So a function to get the data and
we're just going to call it constipation data,
like so. So this is a functional expression. And
this is actually going to be an async function.
Now, to fetch the data, I'm going to use Axios.
So let's import Axios, import Axios from Axios.
Once again, this is the package that
I am using Axios. So import Axios from
Axios. And now I'm going to use Axios. And
we're going to make a GET request to get
the URL, this URL right here, because Okay, so
because our backend is running, that should work.
Of course, if our back end stops running, that we
will not be able to get to this data. And this,
we need to use await as that comes back with
a promise. And let's save this as broker
data, just like so. So they should get the data.
And now I'm actually going to save this. So I'm
going to use use effect to const. Burgers, set
burgers, if you haven't used US state sorry,
use state is the one that we're going to use.
And we're going to use this to set the state
in our app. So of course we have to import it. So
I'm going to import that just above here. Import.
Use state. We're also going to use
use effect I might as well just
import that too. We can short spell it correctly.
From react, okay, so there we go. So
essentially, if I now use set burgers,
so at the moment, our state for burgers is now
but if I use set burgers, I can set boggers to
whatever I wish and I want to set it to the ogre
data, just like so. Okay, so let's check this
out. Let's see if this is working. So what I now
need to do is going to use use effect for this.
And I'm going to pass through a callback function
that will essentially fetch my data, just like
sir. And I was going to pass her an empty array,
so that this doesn't keep on fetching over and
over again. So let's go ahead and do that. Let's
see if that has worked. I'm going to console log
bogus. And see what happens. So let's go
back to our front end. So localhost 3000.
Just inspect the page, a console, log out. And
there we go. So this is what burgers looks like.
Now we actually just want the data. So we're going
to go into the burger data, data. And there we
have our four burger objects. Great. So I'm just
going to go ahead and do that. So burger data,
data. Data. Let's see what that looks like now.
Okay, great. So there we have it, we actually have
an object of four objects. Cool. So this is
looking good. There you go. As you can see,
there they are with their ingredients, and
occasions and so on, I'd actually like to
make an array out of this, so it's easier to work
with. So I'm going to show you how to do that. So
just here as well, I'm going to change this
into an array. Let's actually just save this as
data this time. And I'm going
to get the burger data data.
And for each one I'm going to, so let's get
object keys for it. So I'm going to make some
object keys for it. Because at the moment, it
doesn't have anything to sort of differentiate
each of the objects. And I'm going to map.
So each burger object I'm going to turn into
I'm going to grab it from the burger data.
Data, Data. And I'm going to turn it into
put it into Okay, so now whatever comes back,
I've said that as data, and that is what I'm going
to say, Save As my buggers. And there we go. So
we now have an array of four objects, each with an
object key. Wonderful. I wonder if I do need these
object keys, or if that will just work without
it? No, we do need we need the object keys. Okay,
as does what we are essentially working off.
So there we go. Wonderful. So we have our
four burgers. Now let's get to actually
displaying them in the browser UI. So let's do it.
So for this in here, I'm actually just
gonna create a data go into my favorite
burgers, the styling for this is going to be
extremely minimal. As we have a lot to go through.
I don't want this to be all about styling,
I want you to actually learn how to retrieve
data into an actual project. Okay, so I'm just
going to do this, I'm going to create a div and
this is going to be the bag of feed, maybe give
it a class of burger, fuge. Just like so burger
feed. And in here, I'm just going to
create a card and this is going to
take our burger data. So let's actually map over
each card. Let's actually create a chord first.
So in here, I'm actually going to create
a folder or directory called components.
So new directory, and it's called components.
And then in here, I'm going to create a new
file and score card J S, just like so. And
then let's create our card. So const card,
and then I'm going to return at the moment, I'm
just going to return two types like that. And I'm
going to use export default card not first to use
this card. Okay and other files. So now in here,
I'm going to import the card input card from
make sure to get the path correct. So in here,
opponents Right, yeah, okay. Then, called J
S. Cool. We actually don't need that. Okay,
so this is fine. So now we've imported the
card. And at the moment, we aren't passing
anything through into the card. However, I can
actually start this up. So let's go ahead and
I'm just going to give this a class name just so
you can see what's going on a little bit file.
And I'm going to say card. And now in here in
my style sheet, anything with a class of card,
I'm just going to give a give a height for now of
200 pixels. a width of, let's say, at view width,
and a background color. Of what color should
we go cornflower blue border, radius 40 pixels.
Okay, so at the moment, I've just put in a card.
So there we go. That is, that is my card. Now if
I map all my data onto this, okay, onto each card,
it will actually produce as many cards as I need.
In this case, it's going to be four. So let's go
ahead and do that, I'm just going to pass through
some props into this card. So I'm going to pass
through Well, first off, maybe let's just map.
So let's get our burgers map. We're going to map
each burger, and I'm just going to get that and
card and I'm going to pass through the
burger data. Okay, so this is looking good. As
always, we should probably have a key with this.
Let's just see how this is looking. So there
we go, we've created four cards, as we have for
burgers, let's actually add the key prop as
well. So I can use the key just use the burger ID
as we do have one. So let's go ahead and do
that. Okay, so we are creating the burgers,
let's maybe give each packet some padding
as well. So margin, even margin pixels,
just so it's a bit more space out and on the
card itself, or passing through the burger. So
I'm going to D structure the burger like so the
wise we don't have to get the props. So I'm just
destructuring the burger. And then it's me, this
may be a little bigger. I'm going to sit in here.
Grab that
at each of these. So let's give them an h2 tag.
Let's pass through the burgers name. See what
that looks like. So there you go, you will see
the burger name is being shown just right here.
What else can we pass through, we can pass through
the burger description. Maybe let's make this a
p tag. So there we go. And then we can also
pass through as much information as we wish.
So maybe let's put in a another
P tag and call this burger.
What did we have? Location? And
then burger location? Address.
Okay key location, web. I think that was one
of them. Or was it just website? Website.
You can always check what it was.
Go and hear what the description,
got the name description we've got visited.
We have location is web address web zip code,
probably don't really want the zip code. So I'm
just going to keep it as Web. Okay, so there we
go. And then we could also hide it if we've been
there or you know, which would mean we'd only
see the ones we haven't but that is completely up
to you. Okay, in fact I'm going to do this so if
Berger visited is true. Then we want to hand back.
I don't know what we can return back to sort of
freestyling here, a div that has the class name.
visited. Otherwise, we could just go if it's not
visited, there's probably neater ways to do this,
I am just freestyling here at the moment,
as I said, when we can do not visited,
and it will show based, or show this div if we
visited it, and this one if we haven't visited,
so then I can go visited and just sign up.
And if it's visited, I can just give it
green, or red actually, let's make it red
height 30 pixels with 30 pixels. Border.
Radius 15 pixels, background color,
red as we don't want to see it and if
it's not visited, we'll give it a green.
Okay, and let's make this Okay, so there we go,
we know that this means we visited and the green
means we have not visited these ones yet. You can
replace this with icons, I just wanted to show you
one way of doing that. Wonderful. Okay, so this
is how you would get data, usually document a p i,
and also using the Document Type. Okay, I'm just
going to start this up a tiny little bit before
moving on paddings give the study pixels.
Let's make all the font white font color.
White, of course, please feel free to you know,
take this project really improve on it go crazy
on the styling because that part, my friends
is up to you. This is not a styling course.
Whoops, cannot Okay, so we just have to what is
happening here? It's gonna come out from now.
Okay, so it's not picking stuff up in here.
This is because sometimes the burger data
might not come back fast enough. So I'm just
going to put that right here. Okay, good. Okay,
so it might not read it first time. So the first
time this renders the burger data might not exist,
which is why we put this question mark here. And
when it re renders then that will show these cuts.
Okay, great. So this is looking a lot better.
Great, and then I'm just going to override the
font if there's an h1 tag and give it the font.
color. Black. Cool. And let's just go back here.
That back. Wonderful. And one last thing I would
do on that is center everything. So on the
body itself, I'm going to do display flex
justify content, center text align, center.
Great. So wonderful. I hope you've learned a lot.
Once again, this code will be available to you
in the description. If you're watching this
in the future. Some of these packages might
have changed, just make sure to use these
same packages for this project. Wonderful.
Thanks for watching and onto the next project.
In this project, we're going to learn how to
use the Graph QL API in order to build out
a hotel app. Okay, so once again, I'm going
to start completely from scratch in order to
build out our react up. First things first,
I'm going to create a new database. So hopefully
you are familiar with these steps already,
if you have been following with this tutorial.
So what should we call our database this time,
let's go ahead and call it whatever we wish. So
I'm just going to call it project work again.
Just like so. And it's cool are keyspace
name hotels. The next thing I'm going to do
is just select where I am at the moment. So
I'm going to go ahead and let's pick Europe
and West Europe and just create a database.
Okay, so there we go, there is our database
it is currently being created, you will see
the status as pending. And we're just going to
essentially wait until that is active in order to
start working with it. And there we go. So let's
go ahead and click into here. And then here we
will see our keyspace. Now, the first thing we're
going to do is just head over to the connect tab
in order to start working with our Graph QL API.
We're going to be using this documentation right
here to help us. So the first thing that we need
to do is just create a new application token.
So I'm just going to click here to do that.
And once again, I'm going to select the role
I want. I'm going to choose admin. However,
there are many others with different mutability
levels. And I'm just going to create a token.
Once again, I'm just going to copy this
right here and keep it somewhere safe.
Now, once we have done that, I'm just going to
close that down. And I'm going to launch the
Graph QL playground by clicking right here.
So there we have it, there's our playground
and a row to communicate with our playground, we
need to just put the token we have just created
in the HTTP headers, just like so. So now we can
communicate with our database. Let's go ahead and
create our first table. So I can use the docs to
help me with this. So this is the mutation I'm
going to be using. Once again, if you watch the
tutorials, you will know that we have queries and
mutations to our disposal queries will essentially
find data for us. And mutations can create, delete
and update data for us. So we need to create
a table. So I'm just going to get rid of this.
And this is a mutation. And the mutation that I
want is create a table. Now if we look under here,
you will see that to create a table I need
to the bank indicates that this is necessary,
I need a key space name. So let's go ahead
and pass that through a key space name,
I'm going to put this on a new line. And
the key space name has to be a string.
So I know that my key space name is called
hotels, okay, because that is the key space
that we named it right here. So if I go back
to my databases, hotels is the key space name.
And then the table name, this is something that
I'm going to assign right here, I'm just going
to call it hotel data. So I have just chosen
to assign this to the table name right. Now,
the other necessary thing that we need is a
partition keys as an array. So let's go ahead and
add that partition keys as an array, and I want
my partition key. So if we just click on here,
I need to give it a name and a type. So I'm going
to go ahead and do that, I need to give it a name,
which is a string. So I'm going
to choose to sort all my hotels by
a ID. And then I also need the type. And the type
that I want this to be is actually going to be
basic text. As I don't want this to be an integer,
I want the ID to take letters and numbers. Okay,
so that is one column that we have made. So far
the partition keys. If I want to add more columns,
however, I could do so thanks to values. So once
again, values is an array. So I'm just going to
my values. And if this is one column, this is
actually the column we are going to filter by
and search by. And all these additional ones
are going to come back if we search for this
column. So let's add another column.
Again, we need to have a name for this,
which is going to be the hotel name and
the type for this. I know that I want this
to be text. And if we want to add more columns,
so at the moment, we have one column, a second
column, and I'm going to have three columns
in here. So this is actually going to have the
rating. So I'm going to call this rating.
And I'm going to give this an integer.
Value. Okay, so there we go. So now if we run
this mutation, great, we have created our table.
Wonderful. So now that we have created our table,
let's get to adding data into our table. So
all I'm going to do is navigate into my key
space. So as you can see here, datasets is
actually generated the URL for me, I need to go
into the hotels. So I'm just going to go up here.
And instead of Graph QL schema, I'm just going to
go forward slash hotels to make sure that I'm in
the correct key space. Okay, so there we go. And
now, instead of creating a table, if I look at
the docs, they will be changed, I need to insert
hotel data. So now this is the mutation I need.
Once again, it's a mutation as we are going to
be inserting data. So let's get up mutation.
And this time, I need to use Insert hotel data,
just like sir. And what do we need to put in here,
in order for this to work? Well, I
need to put through a value, okay,
and that is necessary that has got a bang there.
So we have to do it, I'm going to give it a value.
And this time, I'm just gonna give it
the ID, I'm going to make up an ID.
I'm also going to give it a name, so the
name of the hotel, let's say Abby's hotel,
and a rating, which is an integer, so I'm going
to give it a four out of five. So let's just
actually put this on different lines of just
like so. And let's just return back the value
of have a name to check this has worked and
click Run. So great, we have just inserted
some data into our table. Okay, let's go ahead
and just insert some more. So I'm just going
to change these around a little bit. This
time, I'm going to call this set Tories
give it a rating five, there we go. That
has worked. Let's give me another it up.
This time, it's gonna go motel, Mays rating of
three. And then one more, and this one is going to
be awesome. Hotel and give it a rating of five.
Great. So now we know we have just added four
hotels into our database. But how can we actually
see this? Well, for this, we need a query.
So to query this, I would simply I
can go here and have a look, if I need
the queries, I need his hotel data. So I'm just
going to write a hotel data like so. And because
we are not filtering out by anything, I can just
get the values and then choose whichever values
I want to come back so I can get all of them, I
can get the ID, the name and the rating. And just
click that. Or I can just get the name and ID. So
that will return back. Or I can just get the name,
whatever you wish. So however you write that
query is what will return back to you. I want
everything. So I'm just going to do that. And
there we go. So that is essentially the query that
we need in order to get all of our data from our
database. And we also need this Cassandra token
as the HTTP header. And also this URL, as that is
where essentially our data lips. So let's go ahead
and do it. Let's start up our project now. So all
I'm going to do is get my WebStorm up and just
create a new project. Once again, this is going to
be a React project. So I'm just going to use this
and I'm going to call this hotel up just like so.
And using MPX create react app. This should create
a project for me with all the React configuration
ready to go. So I'm just going to click sexer.
And there we go. You will see
my hotel app project right here
and all the dependencies being installed ready
for me to use. Of course you don't have to use
WebStorm. If you're using another code editor
or IDE that is absolutely fine to just make
sure Get Up to this point where your project
is installing all the dependencies ready to go.
And great, we are ready to go. So the first
thing that I'm going to do is actually just
delete anything we don't need. So here are all
the files that have been generated, as well as the
package and all of its dependencies and
scripts. So in here, I'm actually just going to
get rid of the logo as we're not going to need
this anymore. So just delete that. Anyway,
I'm going to delete the report of vitals and
setup tests. So once again, just delete that
as we don't need it anyway. And then I'm going to
delete the app CSS file, as I want all my styling
to be in the index CSS file, and just delete
the app, test J S and just delete that. Okay,
so this is looking good. Just going to
minimize that. And delete this as we
don't have any more I'm going to delete the
semi colons as I'm not a fan of semi colons.
There we go, save that. And then in the
app js file, I'm going to delete all of
this as we don't need it anymore. And
once again, get rid of the semi colons,
and we don't need the logo as we don't have
it. We don't have this file, either. Okay,
so this is looking good. Now, if we run this, I'm
just going to click this to run the start script.
You should see the project show up here, we've got
rid of all the styling, so you should just see a
blank slate, like so. And let's get up our console
log. Wonderful. So now that we have that, let's
get to making some requests. So I'm just going to
minimize that for now. In the previous project,
we built a little mini backend using Express.
However, this time, I'm just going to show you
a different approach. And that is using Netlify
serverless functions. So to do this, let's get off
our terminal and let's install the Netlify command
line interface. So we can use it to npm install.
Net LIFFE phi CLI, and I'm going to install it
globally. Okay, so that is what the juice for
that is to install that locally and just let
that run. Okay, so I'm going to leave that to do
its thing, the next thing we're going to do is
actually create our first serverless function.
Okay, so when that is done, I'm just going
to ask you to create a file in the root of
your project. So make sure it's at the root of
your project on the same level as the package,
Jason is going to minimize that new. And the file
is called net live by tunnel. Okay, and in here,
I'm just going to give you some code to put in
in order to build out the sub list functions.
So this you can just copy, these are some
commands that we're gonna have to put in
here in order to build them out. functions
here is essentially the whatever you call
the directory you want to store your functions
in. So let's go ahead and create that,
I'm going to create that on the same level.
So just make sure that's in the root of your
project and call the directory functions just
like you did here. Okay, so that is where we're
going to store our functions or serverless
functions. And then we just need one more.
Command. Okay, so there we go. Make sure
to write this exactly as I have written it
in a Netlify TOML file in the root of your
project. Great. So now that we have done that,
I'm going to create my first function. So
making sure you are in the functions directory,
create a new JavaScript file, and call it whatever
you want your function name to be. So I'm going to
call this get hotels. And this is a JavaScript
file, so that will add the J S extension.
Now with any surplus function Netlify serverless
function, this is the syntax that you need.
So let's go ahead and write it. I'm
going to have to write export handler
This is an async function. Let's make
this a little bit bigger. Nicholas who no
And then we are going to have to essentially
fetch some data. So just like we did before,
so we're going to import another
directory. So we're going to get
node fetch, I'm just going to install it right
now. API node, fetch, and let that install. Okay.
So while that is installing, let's go ahead and
use it in this file const, fetch equals require
node fetch. Just like that.
Now, as we know, with fetch, we pass through two
things. And that is a URL and options that will
have our HTTP header along with the authorization
token. So let's go ahead and do that.
So once again, let's write the URL. And we
know that the URL, so let's go back to here
is this right here, and this is where
we're gonna make the requests to.
See, I'm just going to paste that in here, like
so. And then Let's also get our options. So const
options, say this is const URL. And the options
are going to have a method, which is a get
request, and the headers, okay, the headers,
which will consist of the content type.
Content Type, and the X, Cassandra token,
okay, so there we go, I'm just gonna make this
the same, as we see here exe Cassandra token,
and I'm just gonna grab that. So the whole thing
and just put it in here, just like, so.
It's gonna make it single quotes. Great.
So we have our options. And then we also have
our new R L, format this a little bit better.
So URL options, I'm going to use Fetch. However,
this time, we're actually going to save whatever
comes back from fetch. So we know this promise,
const response. So whatever that returns back,
we're going to save as response this time.
And this is not all we actually need to do.
And because this time, we actually
have a query to pass through, okay,
so we do have a query to pass through. And
that query is I'm just going to save up here.
So I'm going to save as constant query. And
I'm just going to use backticks for this.
And I'm going to paste in my query. So let's go
in here, this is essentially the query I want to
make. So I'm just going to paste that in here
like so, maybe formatted a little bit better.
We need to pass that query through in with the
options. Okay, so this is no longer a get request,
as we are posting, we are sending this query. So
make sure to change this to a POST method. And
let's get to passing through the query into the
body. So I'm going to pass through the query,
but I need to pass it through JSON stringify and
then pass through the query like so. Okay, great.
So that is looking good. We are now passing
through the query in with our options,
so along with the Cassandra token, the method
and then we are putting that into the fetch
that we imported from node fetch. Great.
Now we're going to use try and catch in order
to do this. So this is the syntax, we'll try
and catch we've got try and I'm going to catch any
errors. So e4 errors. Okay, and to try to do this,
we actually have to make sure
this is all in the export
handler. So let's just grab that and make
sure that it is here. We are going to
what essentially we're getting the response
I'm going to call this was response
body. So we could use this, but we also need
the JSON from it. And this returns a promise.
So I'm going to have to use await in front of it
just like sir. Okay. And then if that comes back,
then we're just going to return a status code
of 200. Because that has worked. And then we are
going to show in the browser, the response. So I'm
going to use JSON, string five for this to work,
I'm going to show the response body in the
browser, and if it doesn't work, where we catch
the errors, and we're just going to console
log the errors, okay? We can also of course,
return a status code to someone do return
status code 500. And I'm just going to show
the error in the actual browser too. So let's
use Jason string phi and pass through if error.
Okay, so this is looking good before we
clean this up, let's just check that works.
So to do this, I'm gonna go in
here and I need to run the command
Netlify. Net LIFFE pi, Dev.
And that is do it's much okay.
So there we go localhost 888. Let's inspect
the page. And now if if we want to get that
data, if we want to run
this function, essentially,
I need to go into functions and get
hotels. Okay? Oops, make sure this is an s.
So, I'm going to go forward slash.net. LIFFE fi,
forward slash functions as the directory that we
created and then get the Taos and wonderful. So
now we are getting all of our data. And Wonderful.
So is saying something's already running on port
3000. I thought I did shut this down. But I didn't
cancel. Okay, so we need to stop that running.
Make sure that stopped. Okay. Essentially,
what is happening here is that localhost 888
is now our front end. Okay, so we don't want
anything running on localhost 3000, because we
want everything to be running on here. Okay.
So that's what we want and to, and essentially,
our front end, and our backend are now on this
URL. So here we go to get our data. And here is
our front end. Great. So I hope that makes sense.
Once again, just make sure that Netlify Deb
is running in order to get that to work.
Wonderful. So once again, I'm just
going to show you the package Jason,
these other packages that I am using, if yours
have changed, or if you're watching it's in the
future, then please use these for the tutorial
in order to get this code here to work. Okay,
so there we go those other packages that
you need, along with their versions.
Wonderful. Now that we have our data, let's get to
clean this up a bit. So just like we did before,
I'm going to create a new file, a dot n v file
in which we're going to store all our secrets.
So once again, I'm just going to put the endpoint
in here. And I'm also going to put in my Astra.
So just like that, and then from here, I'm just
going to get this URL to get the whole thing.
Put it in here. And I'm also going
to get my token, okay, so that we go,
just like so doesn't need to be a
string. You can just save it like that.
Okay, and now this means I can use process EMV
in order to get my Astra token. And I can also
use it to get the URL, but now it's hidden.
Okay. So now it's a bunch safer, and
points. Great. And we have to actually inject
these variables. otherwise this won't work. So I
just inject the variables by running Netlify dev
again. So just like Sir, okay, and you will see
injected endpoint and injected
Astra token. Okay. So there we go.
Let's try that again. Only absolute URLs and
point and point and point A misspelt endpoint.
Okay, so once again, I need
to re inject the tokens
and nullify Dev. Wait for that to be run.
And Wonderful. So now we have a URL or get back
our data. As long as the backend is running,
let's get to using it in the front end. So
I'm done with this. For now let's have a look
if this needs any cleaning up, so here
we have all the code that is necessary,
this will be available to you below. So please
make sure to use it, you don't actually need
to pass through an event for this. This is
looking good. Okay, so there is all my code.
Great. Now let's move on to the front end. So here
is my front end. As you can see here, once again,
I'm going to have to essentially fetch the data.
So I'm just gonna do fetch data just like we did
before, we're gonna make this an async function.
Okay, let's change this to a function expression
just because I prefer working in this way.
And now let's actually fetch the data.
So now this time, I am going to
actually use Fetch. So the Fetch API
going to await it as it's going to come back with
a promise. And I'm just going to fetch this URL
right here. So we're gonna copy that and paste it.
And well, we don't need all of this, I can simply
put forward slash Netlify functions get Hotel.
So that is essentially the same thing. Okay,
so we're getting the data from that. And then
let's go ahead and save it as something. So I'm
going to save it as just the response for now cost
response. Great. So that's the line we need to
write. Now, once we have whatever comes back from
us. So the response need to get is Jason. However,
this also returns a promise. So we need to use a
weight. And let's say this as the response body
this time. And we're going to have to actually
save this into state. So I'm just going to import
use state and also use effect as we're
going to need it later. From react.
Okay, awesome. So we've got the response body,
let's actually save it to the state of the app.
So let's use what should we have hotels, set
hotels, and then use state? I'm going to start
off with the state. No. Okay. So all this means
is that at the moment, hotels is now and I can use
set hotels to make hotels, whatever I wish. But at
the moment, we're starting out with hotels being
not so this gets passed on to that.
And I can use this to also change that.
So I'm going to use the set that tells
to change hotels to the response body.
Wonderful, I think let's check out if this has
worked. So I'm going to now use use of fact.
And then a callback function, you don't know
about use effect, I would suggest doing some
research on these hooks at the moment. So use
effect, just like so I'm going to fetch the data,
okay. And then I'm just going to put up an
empty array, so it doesn't keep fetching
that data over and over again. So I'm going to
call that and now let's console log with health
to see if this has worked and to see
what's being returned back to us.
So now, let's go back here, and just go to the
front end. And there we go. We are getting the
response body data, data, hotel data. So data,
who told data values is what we need, and that
is an array. So I'm just going to go back here and
go response body data, hotel data values. Okay,
in order for that to bring back just the array,
and there we go. We have an array of four tells.
Wonderful, let's carry on. So now that we have
that and we have checked that that has worked,
there's the whole code in its entirety. Please
feel free to stop here and make a note of it
or just catch up, press pause and if you What
up, let's carry on. So just like we did before,
I'm actually just going to map out all
the hotels, I'm not going to create card
component this time as you know how to do
that. So I'm just going to grab the hotels
if they exist. And I'm going to map so dot
map. And for each hotel, well, I wanted to
return a div.
Let's give it a class name of a towel. And then in
here, let's put an h1 tag that has the hotel name,
a p tag that has the hotel, what are the other
ones hotel name, then we have a hotel rating.
So let's see how that looks. And there we go,
we get all four of our hotels with a little
rating, too. Now, let's get to
setting this up a little bit.
So here is my app, I'm just
going to get my CSS file.
Let's put everything in the body as justify
content. Center, of course, we need to use
display flex to initialize this. And align
text, text align, apologies, text, align,
center. Okay, so that is looking good.
And anything with a class of hotel,
I'm going to make sure that the background
color is salmon. And border radius is 50%.
Okay, so maybe that's a
bit too much border radius,
we can of course, change it
as maybe make it just 10%.
Or whatever, really, that
you wish it is up to. Yeah.
Great. So of course, please, again, feel free
to go wild on the styling, I don't want to go
too crazy on the styling. This is not what this
is about. This is a tutorial to show you how to
get data into a project. Okay, so I'm just going
to put my hotels here, and we will let's make
this an age. Tag, like so. Great. And maybe
let's give it some padding from the top,
let's give it 10 pixels. And from each side,
I'm going to go 50 pixels to make it look really
long. Okay, and then also margin. five pixels.
Correct. Okay, so hopefully, you've learned a lot
in how to get data, this time using Graph QL. And
the Graph QL API, if you want to learn more about
how to make more advanced requests. So in making
the functions including stuff like pagination,
I do suggest watch my Netflix clone in
which we use Graph QL to do this, okay,
so that is an option for you. Please try go ahead
and watch that, if you wish, it is reviewed by an
actual Netflix engineer. Once again, the code for
this project will be available in the description
below. And that's it. So to recap, during this
video, cause we have learned what is no SQL,
SQL versus no SQL and why you can't compare them
types of no SQL databases. So document databases,
key value databases, wide column stores or tabular
databases, graph databases and talks about the
multi model databases. We also talked about how to
get data into projects with to real life examples,
and also how to look at the document API and Graph
QL API as we did this. So action packed course
really. And if you're looking for ideas on where
to go next, to really solidify your knowledge,
I would recommend using the Document API and
SDK to build your own Tinder app with me here,
or using the Graph QL API to build a
Netflix clone here, or even learn how
to federate data from two database types with
my Graph QL Federation crypto app right here.
Thanks so much for watching
and I will see you again soon.